moi je me réjouis que pour ce deuxième
tour la participation a été en très
forte hausse
ça veut dire que les autunois ont
compris qu'ils avaient un enjeu qui
avait deux projets deux programmes
différents
et puis qu'ils ont fait confiance aussi
à l'organisation qu'on a mis en place
pour se rendre de manière sécurisée dans
les bureaux de vote
donc je me réjouis de cette victoire
nette avec une participation forte ma
liste était centriste était large pour
autun liste renouvelée puisque deux
tiers des conseils municipaux étaient
nouveau un tiers venait de l'équipe
sortante que j'ai conduite pendant trois
ans mais c'est surtout un projet pour
autant je pense qui a été récompensé